alors quelles réponses apporter à cette
crise économique les 20 pays les plus
riches du monde sont réunis à partir de
ce soir à washington
ils vont tenter les européens en tête de
réformer le système financier
international qui a failli ces dernières
semaines un système créé en 1944
christelle meyrals et michel anglade les
images on vieillit car elle date de 1944
à bretton woods aux états unis une
quarantaine de pays jette les bases du
système financier international
plusieurs institutions sont créées
notamment le fmi le fonds monétaire
international
il avait pour mission de garantir la
stabilité du système monétaire
mais depuis 30 ans son rôle a surtout
consisté à prêter de l'argent aux pays
endettés nouvelle donne avec la crise
actuelle
à washington les grands pays vont tenter
de redéfinir les règles de la finance
mondiale les européens nicolas sarkozy
en tête veulent renforcer le fmi dirigé
par dominique strauss kahn lui donner un
rôle central dans la régulation
financière pour surveiller alerté en cas
de crise le fmi futur gendarme de la
finance mondiale sept économistes n'y
croient pas nous autres européens nous
sommes incapables d'avoir une régulation
prudentielle commune au niveau européen
ce qu'on appelle un superviseur européen
nous avons 27 autorités nationales de
régulation prudentielle c'est à dire
pour la le contrôle des risques des
systèmes bancaires
imaginez qu'on veuille faire un
superviseur mondial et imaginer qu'on
veuille investir le fmi de cette
responsabilité
c'est pratiquement impossible ce serait
déjà un grand pas si nous européens
étions capables de commencer par jeter
les bases d'une supervision européenne
intégrée et après peut-être qu'on pourra
en faire don au reste du monde
les européens espérant tous les cas
avancer sur d'autres chantiers avec plus
de transparence de contrôle des
activités financières en ligne de mire
les fonds spéculatifs et les paradis
fiscaux
et puis réformer les agences de notation
ces agences qui évalue les banques et
non pas vu les dysfonctionnements des
mesures longue à mettre en oeuvre selon
cet économiste
les politiques ont pris la mesure de
l'enjeu la crise qui vient de se
dérouler et une crise extrêmement grave
on n'est quand même pas passé loin d'une
feuille du système bancaire vont
véritablement on a eu très chaud sinon
crise qui est très sérieuse donc je
crois qu'aujourd'hui tous les états et
même les banques centrales et même les
régulateurs nationaux
tous ces gens sont très motivés pour
essayer d'aller de l'avant et pour
mettre un code de la route qui soit peut
être un petit peu plus restrictif mais
le sommet de washington pourrait être
seulement une première étape
george bush en fin de mandat ne devrait
pas prendre de décisions majeures
les européens ont d'ailleurs proposé un
nouveau sommet mondial dans 100 jours
fin février c'est à dire un mois après
l'entrée en fonction de barack obama